[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es das
klassische die klassische beilage die es
eigentlich grillen geben kann nämlich
einen leckeren nudelsalat mit mayonnaise
aber ganz wichtig nicht zu viel sondern
so dass es immer noch leicht schmeckt
ich bin richtig gespannt was ihr zu dem
rezept sagt freue mich auf jeden fall
wenn ihr das fleißig nach macht und
jetzt kommen wir schon direkt zu den
zutaten wir benötigen nudeln das den
korkenzieher nur in diesem jahr ganz
typisch für den nudelsalat und die habe
ich bereits einmal gar gekocht und
komplett abkühlen lassen
außerdem benötigen wir erbsen und zwar
die sehr feinen mais und auch ganz
wichtig gewürzgurken das wasser von den
gewürzgurken das hilft ihnen nicht
wegschütten das brauchen wir ebenfalls
außerdem mayotte ist auch egal ob ihr
die fettarme oder default variante nimmt
etwas ketchup und salz und pfeffer den
mais und die ersten die können wir
direkt schon zu den nudeln geben wie
gesagt es ist ganz wichtig dass die
nudeln schon komplett ausgekühlt sind
[Musik]
soll jetzt müssen wir die gewürzgurken
schön fein würfeln und dann kommen die
auch noch mit hinzu
so falls der ein oder andere jetzt
fleischwurst vermisst ich persönlich bin
der meinung man ist er beim drehen
sowieso schon total viel fleisch aber
ihr könnt natürlich an der stelle dann
auch noch rein tun
doch das ist jetzt vorbereitet und jetzt
geht's an unser leckeres dressing wo
jetzt geben wir ganz einfach alle
zutaten in unsere schüssel als ich hier
die mario tapete heute mal die fettarme
variante genommen aber es gehen durch
mit allen anderen neue varianten auch
außerdem ganz wichtig auch unser
gewürzgurken wasser dass es gibt einfach
so einen ganz typischen geschmack danach
ketchup dazu und salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
so das war's eigentlich auch schon jetzt
gießen wir das nur noch über die
restlichen zutaten grünen das gut um
unter vista salat eigentlich auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
und das war es eigentlich auch schon
jetzt sollte er noch etwa ein bis zwei
stunden durchziehen den kühlschrank am
besten abgedeckt damit auch die
flüssigkeit richtig schön in den nudeln
eingezogen werden kann
aber ich muss dazu auch sagen das ist
generell so auch wenn das nudelsalat ist
etwas leichtere variante denn der ist
nicht so
mayonnaise lass dich ich finde nämlich
es gibt nichts schlimmeres als wenn man
beim grillen sitzt und dann so ein
richtig fertigen mayonnaise salat ist so
nach zwei stunden zeit ist der salat
jetzt perfekt optimal
jetzt könnt ihr raus zum grillen und den
salat genießen ist super lecker probiert
ihn unbedingt mal nach einem rezept aus
ich gehe doch ein bisschen raus wir
jetzt den sonnenstrahlen genießen ein
bisschen was den teint machen kiffe den
tag
und ja dann sage ich bis zum nächsten
mal auf die gis kitchen jeans
[Musik]